-Welcome back, everybody!
We have a really great show
tonight.
It's a really fun show, and --
I don't know, man.
I just --
-What?
-I just feel like --
I don't know.
I just feel like I gotta --
I gotta blow off some steam.
-What?
-I just feel like I've got to --
it's been a rough week,
you know?
It's been one of those weeks.
You just gotta get out there,
and blow off some steam.
Helmet me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's it. Just gonna go out!
Get in this mustang.
I had a rough week.
Blow some steam off here.
Let me get in the car,
put my seatbelt on,
and burn some rubber!
Whoohoo!
Yeah, with my blinker on.
Yeah!
Alright, yeah!
This is wild!
Wow! Yeah! Whoo!
E-brake by this abandoned
factory. Here we go.
Ha ha ha ha!
Sorry to leave! See you later!
Here we go!
Doughnut time!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo! Look at me now, man!
I'm alive! I'm alive!
[ Panting ]
That felt good.
That felt real good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
[ cheers and applause ]
That Mustang was badass.
Thank you to Ford. Go check out
the 2024 Ford Mustang
at Ford.com.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
♪♪
-♪ Yeah, what comes around
goes around ♪
♪ Like the vortex ♪
♪ Competition, I'm all for it,
quartet ♪
♪ Choke 'em out... ♪